♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, PRETTY MUCH
SINCE THE DAY JOE BIDEN GOT
INAUGURATED YOU'VE BEEN HEARING
IN THE MEDIA EVERY DAY THAT THE
STATE OF FLORIDA IS A COVID
HOT SPOT AND VIRTUALLY EVERY
PERSON IN THE STATE HAVE DIED OF
THE CORONAVIRUS.
SUDDENLY YOU ARE NOT HEARING
THAT ANYMORE.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS ARE TOO
STARK TO DENY.
IN THE LAST SEVEN DAYS, FLORIDA
HAS AVERAGED FEWER COVID CASES
PER CAPITA THAN NEARLY ANY STATE
IN UNITED STATE, RANKS 48TH OUT
OF 50.
NOW THE GOVERNOR OF THE STATE
RON DeSANTIS HAS ANNOUNCED A
SPECIAL LEGISLATIVE SESSION TO
BAN COVID-19 RELATED VACCINE
MANDATES, NOT JUST BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA
RON DeSANTIS JOINS US NOW.
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
SO, IF YOU WOULD EXPLAIN WHAT
THIS WOULD MEAN AND WHY YOU ARE
DOING IT.
>> TUCKER, OVER MORE THAN
ANYTHING, THIS IS AN INDIVIDUAL
CHOICE.
YOUR LIVELIHOOD SHOULD NOT BE
DEPENDENT ON WHETHER YOU GET A
COVID SHOT, MUCH LESS IN THE
FUTURE, IF THESE MANDATES TAKE
HOLD, WHETHER YOU GET YOUR
YEARLY BOOSTER OR BOOSTER EVERY
SIX MONTHS OR WHATEVER THEY ARE
GOING TO MAKE YOU DO.
THIS IS A PERSONAL DECISION.
NUMBER TWO, WHAT BIDEN IS DOING
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND WE HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY AS A STATE TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST FEDERAL
OVERREACH.
BUT THEN, NUMBER THREE, THIS IS
NOT GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY.
THIS IS JUST BAD POLICY.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF BUSINESSES
THAT ACTUALLY NEED PEOPLE,
PARTICULARLY IN HEALTH CARE, AND
WHAT, YOU ARE GOING TO GIVE
PEOPLE WALKING PAPERS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS?
SO I THINK IT IS BAD ALL AROUND
AND I THINK YES, WE ARE GOING TO
BE DOING LITIGATION AGAINST THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WHICH IS
IMPORTANT, BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
DO LEGISLATION TO BUY
PROTECTIONS FOR FOLKS IN
FLORIDA.
I TELL YOU, TUCKER, YES, BIDEN
IS DOING MANDATES THAT I
DISAGREE WITH THAT, I THINK WE
ALL DO, BUT THERE ARE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE DOING THIS ON THEIR
OWN, EVEN APART FROM THE
MANDATES, AND THESE ARE
EMPLOYEES OF THEIRS THAT HAVE
BEEN WORKING THROUGHOUT THIS
WHOLE PANDEMIC, AND NOW THEY ARE
BEING TOLD YOU GET YOUR WALKING
PAPERS?
THAT IS NOT A FREE CHOICE.
YOU KNOW, TUCKER, WE HAD A NURSE
TODAY AT OUR EVENT, SHE HAS
ALREADY HAD COVID AND SHE IS
PREGNANT RIGHT NOW, AND SO SHE
SAYS, I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
I DON'T WANT TO DO.
HOW IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU
WERE GOING TO DEPRIVE HER OF HER
RIGHT TO MAKE A LIVING BASED ON
THAT VERY REASONABLE DECISION?
>> Tucker: SO, THE WHITE HOUSE
IS VERY FOCUSED ON YOU AND YOUR
STATE AND THIS IS THE
CENTERPIECE OF THEIR DOMESTIC
AGENDA, VACCINE MANDATES, WHAT
THEY CARE ABOUT MOST.
SO IF YOU OPENLY DEFY THEM, I
MEAN, ARE YOU EXPECTING THEM TO
HIT BACK, TRY TO CHOKE OFF
FEDERAL HEALTH CARE MONEY TO THE
STATE, OR DO YOU EXPECT SOME
KIND OF CONFRONTATION WITH THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
>> WELL, I'M SURE THEY ARE GOING
TO DO WHATEVER THEY CAN.
TUCKER, OVER THE SUMMER WHEN WE
HAD DEALT A HIT, I STARTED A
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODY PROGRAM
BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE BEING
ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL WITHOUT
GETTING EARLY TREATMENT.
SINCE WE PUT THAT PROGRAM IN, OR
DAILY ADMISSIONS HAVE GONE DOWN
90%.
AS WE WERE DOING THAT, BIDEN TRY
TO CUT OFF THE SUPPLY TO FLORIDA
BECAUSE THIS IS WORKING, AND SO
I IMAGINE THEY ARE DEFINITELY
GOING TO DO SOMETHING TO TRY TO
HIT BACK, BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, DO YOU THINK -- DO YOU WANT
TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S JOBS OR DO
YOU NOT?
AND I'M GOING TO BE ON THE SIDE
OF PROTECTING PEOPLE'S JOBS, AND
IF JOE BIDEN WANTS TO BE ON THE
SIDE OF CAUSING PEOPLE TO LOSE
THEIR JOB, WELL, THEN WE WILL
LET HIM DO THAT AND WE WILL
FIGHT THE GOOD FIGHT.
>> Tucker: YEAH, BECAUSE HE
KNOWS MORE ABOUT MEDICINE THE
NURSES AND DOCTORS.
SO, THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS IS A
REAL CRISIS.
A YEAR AGO, IT COST 3 GRAMS TO
MOVE A CONTAINER FROM ASIA TO
THE EAST COAST OF THE
UNITED STATES, NOW 20 GRAND, SOT
OF THE U.S. ECONOMY.
YOU SAY YOU HAVE A SOLUTION OR
PART OF A SOLUTION TO THIS, WHAT
IS IT?
>> SO, WE HAVE CAPACITY AT ALL
OF OUR PORTS.
REMEMBER, TUCKER, THEY MADE A
BIG DEAL ABOUT L.A. STARTING
24/7, WE ALWAYS DO 24/7 IN
FLORIDA.
WE'VE GOT CAPACITY AT ALL OF OUR
PORTS TO OFFER THESE BUSINESSES
GOOD INCENTIVES IF THEY REROUTE
THEIR SHIPS.
WE HAVE ALREADY HAD SOME SHIPS
REROUTED.
WE EXPECT TO HAVE MORE.
BUT IF YOU WERE GOING TO SIT OFF
THE COAST FOR DAYS ON END, YOU
MIGHT AS WELL BRING INTO
FLORIDA, WE HAVE GREAT LOGISTICS
ON THE GROUND THAT CAN GET IT TO
MARKET AND WE ARE HAPPY TO BE
ABLE TO STEP UP BECAUSE THERE
ARE AND THE SHELVES.
THIS IS DRIVING INFLATION.
THIS IS GOING TO CAUSE
SHORTAGES, WE ALREADY SEE
SHORTAGES, GOING TO AFFECT THE
CHRISTMAS SEASON, SO I THINK
FLORIDA CAN BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
>> Tucker: THE MORE FLORIDA
ACTS LIKE A COUNTRY, I THINK
THAT IF ALL OF US, MY